wherever he may be in the world ismail
abadi is now very much a wanted man
after refusing to give evidence at a
public inquiry into one of britain's
deadliest terror attacks carried out by
his brothers today a warrant for his
arrest was issued
he is someone lawyers believe can assist
the inquiry with understanding how his
brother murdered 22 people how both
salman and hashem became radicalized and
why his dna was found on a hammer used
to make the lethal bomb throughout the
whole inquiry he's done everything he
could to not give evidence he he made it
very clear from the start of the inquiry
that he didn't really want to
participate in the process therefore it
should have been highly suspicious that
he was leaving the country or seeking to
leave the country and had he been
stopped from leaving the country would
not be in this position now
it was in august last year ishmael abedi
attempted to leave the uk at manchester
airport
on the 28th he was stopped and
questioned by police but the following
day he managed to leave and hasn't
returned since
it was clear when i interviewed ishmael
abadi a few years ago he wanted to leave
manchester in his words he told me i
hate this place i want to get out of
this country but his action to flee the
uk
comes with a heavy price well he put
himself in a deeper hole bro growing up
in manchester ahmed was a close friend
of the abadies particularly ishmael
speaking to us from libya he says the
oldest brother will know he's now a
convicted criminal he fought instead of
me getting deeper into this case
and uh giving evidence or giving this
kind givingness is that let me bounce in
my family
and go to somewhere where they cannot
find me no one can find but despite
understanding his reasoning for leaving
ahmed says coming home and coming clean
is the right move i think for him
it's better it's better it's better yeah
it's better if he just goes boxes flight
comes back to england and hands himself
in
the chances of that are slim and for
those who want justice the agonizing
weight continues well this has been a
joke the way he just walked away
got on his jollies makes his second side
and we've let him we've let them walk
out because we've had all of them
and we've let them go
basically what did he say or i'm not
telling you
ismail abadi could be on the receiving
end of a 12-month sentence but without
his presence in a british court that
won't be possible it leaves many
questions unanswered
and many doors unclosed in zaman rashid
sky news manchester